de lessive les gens sont sur leur
fauteuil sur leur canapé ou dans le bar
à regarder un écran de foot
et donc en revanche à la mi-temps vous
allez le voir sur cette courbe une
reprise de consommation à 20h50 avec des
supporters qui changent de pièces qui en
aluminent une autre qui font chauffer de
l'eau ou un petit truc à manger ça fait
un demi gigawatt de plus
c'est important plus près de toi ça y
est on a fait la fête c'est bon
leur douzième homme est au ciel depuis
quelques temps Diego Maradona il prit
Maradona et il
était sur BFM TV avec un journaliste
argentin qui parle de mystique qui parle
de ce que de tout ce que l'Argentine
fait depuis que Maradona est mort
c'est-à-dire gagner un Copa América et
d'autres et d'autres titres vous
connaissez désormais le refrain
ce morceau a été écrit par Gala
elle-même alors qu'elle sortait avec un
mec fauché
mais loin des valeurs olympiques c'est
une autre réalité que ces hommes
décrivent on sait qu'il y a pas mal de
personnes qui sont là qui n'ont pas de
papier qui travaillent ils ont peur de
parler une peur que ces travailleurs
maliens sans papiers ont décidé de
surmonter pour dénoncer l'attitude de
leurs employeurs et si les Bleus y
arrivent ils pourront rapporter très
gros à la Fédération Française de
Football la finale des Bleus assure 30
millions de dollars à la FFF et en cas
de victoire en phase finale de la Coupe
du Monde la FIFA qui redistribue une
partie de ses bénéfices vers ce même 40
millions d'euros à la FFF soit presque 7
fois plus qu'en 1998 on va commencer à
8h les reciplémentaires 17h 18h à 20h et
Paypal des heures supplémentaires non
payées et parfois pas de fiche de paye
il va donner
de son meneur de jeu qui brandit
l'enceinte et pas encore la coupe cette
équipe s'amuse même lorsque le contrôle
antidopage retient Jules Kunde et
Ibrahima Konaté
[Musique]
ça marche bien
si vous êtes détendu c'est nickel j'ai
pas du tout vu le ballon arriver je l'ai
pris en plein visage à une puissance et
vraiment je suis tombé d'un coup j'ai
été complètement chaos et tu repars
et que j'espère pouvoir faire dédicacer
par Kilian pour pour le souvenir de
cette demi-finale ce livre audio c'est
très important
et justement j'ai mon livre là je pense
que il est à l'endroit
il est à l'envers regardez hop là
c'est cool les drapeaux maghrébins le
drapeau musulman sont restés très
visibles dans une sorte d'appropriation
on a compris vous avez un journaliste
qui dit ta gueule ta gueule et il traite
également de réflexion cônes et il met
en danger les gens qui font cette chaîne
Martin Bouygues est-ce que vous tolérez
ça c'est une question que je pose et à
laquelle ils pourront évidemment
répondre oui moi ça m'écoutez j'ai
travaillé avec Martin Bouygues
qui a dit ça
on a dit non aux trois regardez les
bandeaux qu'ils mettent en bas de
l'écran victoire du Maroc des violences
gâchent la fête qui se change en je ne
dis pas que un naturellement un musulman
ne puisse pas l'immigration quelle
solution ce qui est sûr c'est que le
visage de cette équipe et on le voit
bien d'ailleurs et des visages issus de
l'immigration qui sont sur représentées
dans cette dans cette équipe
indéniablement
il y en aura une troisième dimanche soir
elle est là la troisième pour vous on
vous la donne
donc je ne suis pas sûr qu'elle soit
tout à fait représentative des
équilibres entre voilà français
d'origine française et française
d'origine immigrée et on va dire ta
gueule
[Musique]
juste à la fin de la rencontre entre la
France et le Maroc c'est un groupe de 40
personnes qui a été interpellé lors d'un
contrôle groupe proche de l'extrême
droite dont des membres étaient armés et
qui s'apprêtaient à commettre des
violences sur les Champs-Élysées j'ai
les records mon truc sur la tête
j'ai honte avec Monsieur le Maire
oui non pas du tout bah tu sais je suis
sorti en boîte de nuit ici à peu près 70
ans au Macumba j'ai fait connaissance
d'une personne et là j'ai appris que
j'avais un fils
c'est lui
c'est dingue non mais tu sais qui a
Perpignan on apprend des trucs c'est
assez dingue vous allez chanter pour
gagner 20 000 € et si vous gagnez 20000
€, vous partagez entre tout les icônes
voici la pyramide il y a évidemment 1000
€ avec deux mots à découvrir dans la
chanson la même chanson plus loin 2000
euros beaucoup plus de beaucoup plus
loin 5000 euros énormément de 10000
euros et la totale
de retour à leur campbase les Bleus sont
toujours en train de chanter
à l'étage Adrien rabiot malade hier il a
vu le match confiné à l'hôtel il filme
le retour de ses coéquipiers
excusez-moi pardon excusez-moi mais on a
vraiment pas le temps de jouer la finale
on est beaucoup trop longue
avec une autre surprise évidemment je me
disais c'était pas possible c'était trop
beau et
moi alors que moi c'est pas fini pour
vous